- So you recently got hearing aids.
So are you into this or not into this?
What?
(audience laughing)
Are they in today?
- I'm still a smidge vain,
so they're not in for our little
- Oh, they're not?
- tete a tete.
No.
- Wait, why be vain?
Wait, well, what's new?
- No, no, no, no, I
wear them, I love them.
I love my hearing aids.
- Okay.
- They're brilliant.
They are, they changed my life.
- Yeah.
What do you hear now that
you do didn't hear before?
(audience laughing)
Like.
- All the, the wind that I
break that I used to think was
(audience laughing)
- You thought it was silent.
- Mary would say, "Ted!
People can hear you!"
- And I'd go, come on, they can't hear me,
of course not.
- Just ripping.
- And the first time
it went on, had them in, it
was like, oh my God, they
(audience laughing)
I'm sorry.
- For years.
- Yeah.
- Oh, you're that guy.
That's amazing.
- Yeah.
- Well, speaking of breaking wind,
I heard that you had a, is
this true, a psychologist?
- And if you can't have fun with a fart.
- Farting is funny.
- Oh my God
- I feel sorry for people.
- Farting is funny.
Everyone does it.
I heard that you had a psychologist once
tell you like for like
theater or something
or like on stage,
- No.
- were you nervous?
- It was,
we all went to this,
we got out Carnegie Mellon University
and we all went to New York
and it was still like almost
living in a dormitory,
but we all used the same psychologist
'cause life was too scary at that moment.
Anyway, he told us,
told one of us, then it got around,
you're too uptight.
You should be farting like a Jack rabbit.
Who knew about Jack rabbits, but
- What?
- that has become
our little family motto, yeah.
- Oh my God.
So you just like cropped
us people on stage,
like you're just.
- I personally, no.
- Okay
or maybe you didn't hear it.
- Woody Harrelson.
Woody Harrelson.
- It was like its own
instrument in the Kelly song.
- Yeah.
And he was a vegetarian.
- That's why.
- This is my chance to get Woody.
He would stand next to me
and engage me and he was very cool guy.
And he would say,
Ted, I really want your
opinion on something
and I'd be touched
and I'd move in closer to hear
it and give it my best shot.
And he would just be looking
at my eyes like a murderer
waiting for it to rise
- For it to rise
- and see the horror
and dismay on my face.
- I'm like, oh my God.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
I love that story.
- That's Woody Harrelson.
- That's amazing.
That's horrible
to do to someone.
- Horrible, yeah.
- Especially when they breathe it in
and they're like, I just ate it.
Like it's like,
like no gross.
Okay, well let's, there's no segue there.